all right now i finally get to share
with you
a method for average treatment effect
estimation based on machine learning
that's actually good so all right
what do i mean by this well the average
treatment effect
we've been talking about it for a while
we want to estimate the average
treatment effect
um under uncompoundedness um there's no
question
here but of course the thing i look more
implicit
what do i mean by actually good
and by this i mean an estimator with
kind of parametric type guarantees
we want an estimator tau hat that
converges to the average treatment
effect at a root and scale
that satisfies the central limit theorem
and that's going to enable
us to build confidence intervals in the
usual way
why is this a notion of good um well
if in the classical setting of
parametric modeling if you were to run
linear regression with a well-specified
model
this is essentially what you'd expect
you could get root and rate confidence
samples
so if you're using machine learning
uh then you'd hope that at the end of
the day you get something
um with comparably good properties as to
what you could get out of traditional
parametric modeling which is kind of
under more flexibility
so this is what we want what do we have
uh we have machine learning uh but
that's of course
again rather nebulous so now
i'll need to be more specific again
about what i mean by
access to machine learning and this by
this i mean we have access to a
predictive
black box that's good that's flexible
but that's not too good um
and what i'll say specifically is that
we have
a way of estimating this mu hat and e
these mu and e functions the conditional
response function and the propensity
score
that converges in root mean square there
at a fourth root n right uh here
remember
n is the sample size so
this might look like something of a
strange assumption um
okay uh why this
uh well first the first thing to note is
kind of how are we writing this
assumption down
and we're writing this assumption down
in terms of the root mean squared error
rmsc why is this natural well
remember the claim of machine learning
methods is that they're good
at the claim is that machine learning is
good at
prediction under squared or loss like i
mentioned earlier
being good at prediction means having
small mean squared error um the optimal
predictor under squared error loss uh
would just be kind of using mu w x and e
of x
the optimal prediction y and y giving w
and x
is mu w x all right
so machine learning claims to be good at
prediction that means it must be
claimed to be good at rmse and also in
fact if you tune your machine learning
method
for predictive accuracy then you're
simultaneously tuning it to be as good
as possible
in terms of rmse so the reason i want to
be using this assumption
is i want to be assuming things of
machine learning methods that they
actually claim to be good at
as opposed to assuming something else
so this is about the functional form the
second question is why the fourth route
down here
um this is a more delicate question um
if this were kind of a stats phd
class i would talk for a while about the
exponent here
and debates about what is optimal
exponent here and trade-offs
um but for our purposes um the main
things to note is first this rate of
convergence
fourth root of n it's smaller than one
over square root of f
that is kind of for big values of n one
over fourth root of n is bigger than one
over squared
um so this is a less stringent
assumption
uh if you had a parametric model then
traditional parametric methods
of estimation could get you one over
square root of n rates of convergence
and here what we're assuming is
that you you have some convergent
guarantees that are weaker than one over
square root of n
that's the important uh we're not
assuming uh parametric convergence in
and now we need some
number here i made a big deal about why
this is kind of a weaker guarantee than
assuming
one over square root and rate
convergence now we need something here
one over four through then i'm just
using it as something that's convenient
that'll enable simple formal results um
and that's also kind of obviously uh
weaker than what you get in parametric
problems so there's some room
for kind of machine learning to be doing
a good but not perfect job at prediction
so all right this is what we have and
then the question is how can we use
this predictive white box to reach our
goal that is estimate the average
treatment
and so the answer ends up being
um we've talked about methods based on
regression adjustment
where you only estimated the mu
functions and then you try to form an
average treatment effect estimator based
on those
and that didn't really work and we've
talked about
methods based on inward propensity
weighting uh where you only estimated
the propensity score the e function
and try to use that for average
treatment effect estimation
and again that wasn't accurate uh what's
gonna work
is that you need to estimate both models
and combine them in a clever way that
trades off
the errors of each model against each
other
and how do you do this well for now i'll
just write down the answer
you want to use the following functional
form for the estimator
how this estimator is called augment the
augmented inverse propensity weighted
estimator
or aipw and
the short story is that in considerable
generality this is a good estimator of
the average treatment effect
even when the mu hats and e hats were
obtained
from a machine learning method
so i guess
in looking at this your first reaction
might be like
that's a cool guarantee but uh but
maybe maybe you feel like i've lost you
here this is
this is a very complicated looking
estimator
i feel like stefan i like what you're
telling me but
i've never used an estimator in any of
my
papers that took two lines of to write
down
and maybe you don't feel like changing
that
and i understand the sentiment but i
hope
i can convince you that the estimator
kind of once you understand what it's
doing
it's not quite as bad as the functional
form suggests
uh so what's going on here instead of
just writing it as a giant blob
let's write it in two parts um first
i'm going to kind of cut it up into the
orange part
um and second blue part which is kind of
the rest here and now
okay if we write these two parts
separately so we have the blue part
and the orange part these are the same
from last slide
then we can we can interpret them as
balls
the orange part this is actually
something familiar this is with
something we've seen before
on average from i equals one up to n
of mu had one of x i minus mu had zero
of x i
this was just the machine learning based
regression adjustment we talked about
at the beginning of this lecture and
part two
um we talked about how
under flexible conditions the new hats
you get out of
uh machine learning are going to be
consistent so
this term uppercase d is going to be
consistent with the average treatment
effect
under considerable generality but
the machine learning methods don't
converge fast enough and so d is not
going to converge at a squared
end rate there's going to be bias and we
can't get confidence intervals
so d is something we have seen before
then the question is what is this r term
here
this is kind of a correction that we
apply to d and
here if you stare at this and you
compare it
to the ipw estimator we just saw earlier
this should actually look quite familiar
uh what was ipw ipw
uh looked like this so ipw
was the average over
n of um i equals one up to n
of wi over e hat times y i and
1 minus wi over 1 minus e hat times
y so if you just had the red stuff here
then this term r would look like what
you got
um out of ipw
this was this was the thing we had
before
what happens now is that this term r
is applying ipw but it's not applying
them to the original outcomes y i
it's applying them to these residuals
here
y i minus mu hat 1 of x i in the case of
the treated units
and y i minus mu has 0 x i in the case
of the control units
and this might seem like a strange thing
to do
but here's the intuition imagine
you were kind of listening along um
in in part two of this lecture with the
regression adjustment
and you kind of liked the regression
adjustment and you felt like this was a
pretty good estimator
but then i told you look machine
learning methods have errors
the regression adjustment leaves these
errors on the table uh this
this means there's bias so we can't use
the regression adjustment alone
you feel okay maybe maybe this isn't
perfect
maybe the regression adjustment left
some signal
there but i'll just try to patch it up
afterwards
i'll try to kind of salvage that signal
um and kind of apply a correction uh to
the basic kind of regression estimator
capital d
so here's what's going on this kind of y
i minus mu hat one
this is kind of a measure of how much
signal
kind of if this you had one of x i were
a perfect
prediction of why i saw this uh so this
was kind of just mean zero noise
irreducible noise
then this kind of r term would be
essentially zero
but if it's true that there actually is
some signal left
over from the first progression stage
then you should expect that there's some
signal
left here and some signal left in these
residuals
that kind of uh is a measure
of the bias of this pure kind of orange
regression adjustment estimator
and now kind of you might have this wild
hope that you can just take these
residuals
and extract the information that was
left over
by throwing these uh
residuals into ipw kind of you start
with the regression you have two ways of
estimating an average treatment effect
the regression adjustment and ipw so
what you're going to do is first run the
regression adjustment
and then use ipw to fix up
the regression adjustment and kind of
soak up any information that was
left over this might seem like a wildly
optimistic idea
but turns out it works very nicely
so let's see let's play out an example
uh here
it's a simple simulation uh not a
parametric function
uh notice these uh positive parts here
and we want to estimate the average um
treatment
average treatment effect in this setting
is going to be negative 0.05
first thing you could try just estimate
uh these
mu zero mu1 functions using a random
forest
take the average difference in
predictions this is the regression
adjustment estimator
uh you can do it it's going to be
consistent is it going to be
particularly good
well here on average we get an answer of
0.09 when the true treatment effect is
negative 0.05
okay but not great so what we're going
to want to do
um is then patch this up and correct it
and so here what we're going to do in
the
in the second step is we're going to fit
a propensity model
uh e hat we're going to apply ipw
to the residuals of the random forest
this is going to give us this correction
term
r and then we're going to add this
correction term r
to the original estimator so here
the correction term r is negative 0.1
our estimator from before with 0.09
um and when you add them together then
you get this
point estimate of negative 0.01
which again isn't perfect but it's a lot
closer to the true answer
than the original regression adjustment
to kind of get an idea of
how good is this um i'm here showing a
box plot
of kind of across 100 replications of
the treatment effect estimates
you get so here this is first the box
plot of the regression adjustment
estimators
and you see is really not that good
kind of the true answer is here negative
on average the treatment effect here is
positive
and not only that but kind of in every
single realization
in the simulation setting uh
the regression adjustment gives you
treatment of existence that's bigger
than the truth
so you don't even have any spread of
this box plot around the truth
then here this is the correction it's a
remarkably stable correction here
it just kind of pushes this box plot
down and then aibw
what do you get well you get the follow
it's again
uh not perfect we're not nailing this
answer
uh this is again kind of there's some
final example phenomena here
suggesting we're not kind of in a
perfect
asymptotically unbiased type uh regime
yet
but still on average aipw is much closer
to the correct answer
than the kind of regression adjustment
on its own and also you see that now at
least
the true treatment effect starts to be
within the spread
of things you could get out of aipw
and there are some simulation
replications where aipw falls below
is negan has a negative rather than a
positive error
so here the correction helped
all right um
on the side i just want to make uh still
so i hope this helps a little bit in
reassuring that this kind of
daunting ipw functional form uh
it has a simple explanation let's run a
regression adjustment
then take the residuals and stick them
into
a pw even so
you might feel like this is a lot to
implement and again something i
want to reassure you is that kind of
once you know that aipw is a thing you
want
is the thing to do when estimating
average state and defects
using machine learning then kind of
hopefully you can find a software-based
solution that implements it for you
for example in the in the package grf
that um susan and i maintain
um you can
run this function causal forest under
the hood what this is going to do it's
going to do a bunch of stuff
we're going to talk about it more in
upcoming weeks but it's going to give
you the mu hat and e
hats based on random forests for the
things you need
and then if you want to an aipw you can
just call a function average treatment
effect
on the causal forest object and we're
gonna
do all of this for you so anyways
it's a it's a question in some cases you
may want to implement this on your own
but often um when you're running this in
practice you don't need to deal with
kind of the
massive functional form
all right that's aipw that's what it
looks like algorithmically
procedurally but i've been kind of
typing this up for a while now saying
that it's good so
let's actually talk about the sense in
which aipw does give you a good estimate
of the average strength
and the key result here is that
aipw actually satisfies the theorem
that we tried to prove about
ipw that is just kind of plain inverse
propensity waiting
ah but didn't go through and so like
did there i'm going to start by writing
down this oracle version of
aipw so if you remember from a couple
slides ago
this thing i'm highlighting in orange
this is exactly the same
as the aipw estimator except
every time when there's a mu or an e i'm
putting the true value of mu and e in
here
not the estimated uh mu hat or e-hat
that you got
um out of
the machine learning method and
the strategy here is going to be to show
that
under reasonable assumptions about the
machine learning um
methods that this
the feasible aipw estimator that uses
these kind of estimated muhatsam e hats
is gonna be equivalent to first order
is going to behave just like this oracle
aipw estimator that uses the true values
of mu
in the case of ipw we tried to prove
this kind of result
but it turned out that kind of at least
using our proof strategy
uh the discrepancy between the feasible
tau hat and the oracle one
uh was was much
larger than the kind of target error
scale whereas here the opposite is going
to be true
and the theorem
is essentially the following um this is
kind of a very simple version of a
result
of which there are many alternatives out
there in the literature
i'll point you some more references um
at the end of this lecture
but so let's start by assuming
um what i assumed earlier that is that
all our estimates we get out of machine
learning are
not perfectly accurate they're not
converging at a root and rate
but they're pretty accurate they
converge at a fourth grade
then um
the feasible estimator tau hat and the
oracle up there in orange
are equivalent at the squared and scale
meaning if you take their difference and
you blow it up by square root n
this converges in probability to zero
their first order equivalent
i'm not going to prove this result of
here it's beyond the scope of this class
if you want to see
a proof please send me a note um i'm
happy to
have you share a reference um in
particular
um on the last slide i'll have some
references kind of
kind of prove this kind of result in the
case of specific machine learning
methods
um also in the stats 361 class i teach
that there are lecture notes that i
referred to in the syllabus
and in chapter three of those notes
there's a proof
of this kind of result but for now
i just want to kind of emphasize the
form of the result
and contrast it to what we got with
ipw with ipw
we kind of tried to bound the
discrepancy between the oracle and
feasible
estimators and what we found is that if
the propensity score
converges at one over four through then
and root mean squared error
then the discrepancy between the
feasible and oracle estimators
well you can bout it to order four
through that there was no gain there
you were limited by the accuracy of the
method you put out
but here something else happens uh we
have
a bunch of regression adjustments and
we're only assuming that they converge
at fourth root n
and yet the error kind of the effect
of kind of plugging these mu hats and e
hats with fourth through then scale
errors
into this estimator
results in kind of only alters this
estimator
to scale that's less than one over root
so
this somehow violates this garbage and
garbage out principle
where you think if you kind of plug
stuff into here
with fourth root and scale errors then
you must kind of induce fourth root and
scale
errors in the final product but that's
not true
you can plug in fourth and scale errors
but essentially
this estimator is very carefully
designed in a way
that makes it that kind of first order
errors and you have an e hat cancel out
and that's why kind of you can plug in
components of fourth root and scale
errors into here
and in the end you change the final
result by less than one over root n
and you get this kind of result what
this means
is that we can do what we actually
wanted to do with ipw
that is we can just study this object
give a central limit theorem for it
that's going to convert that one over
squared
and rate and then we can use this kind
of
result to invoke or to argue that
actually tau hat
aipw also satisfies any guarantees you
proved about
and kind of concretely i just
again this tau tilde here if you know
this new
e stuff um again this is a big
expression but this is just an average
of iid terms averages of iid terms
satisfy central limit theorems in
considerable generality
as discussed earlier so what you can
check
is that this oracle estimator is going
to
be asymptotically normal with one over
root and deviations around the true
average treatment effect tau
you can check that its
variance is going to depend on this
quantity b star
and really the point here is that
because
tau hat aipw and
tau tilda aipw are equivalent on the
root and scale
then kind of once you've got this
central limit here
for the oracle estimator you also get
this central limit theorem for the
feasible estimator
where we've plugged in machine
learning-based nuisance parameters
so this is the first result i've given
you
today where you don't need to
use parametric models you can just start
from kind of machine learning
reasonable assumptions on machine
learning combine
predictions from a bunch of different
machine learning models and you land on
your feet
you get an estimate for the average
treatment effect
that has classical gaussian
parametric rate behavior
so you get a central limit theorem uh
that's very good
uh it turns out actually that this v
star we got here
uh it's a very good uh variance
parameter
and actually this is the best central
limit theorem you could get
uh for average treatment effect
estimation using any method
um under kind of non-parametric
assumptions
so that's again beyond the scope of this
class but just kind of this isn't just
any central limit theorem it's a good
one too
so this is nice um and actually
the proof uh gives you more
than what i wrote down
it actually tells you that kind of okay
algorithmically you can write
tau hat aipw
as the average of these capital gamma
hat eyes
i'm going to call these things double
robust scores
you're going to see them occur several
times in this class
so you can think of tauhan aipw as being
an average of double robust scores and
these double robust scores of course
are not iid
they're not independent from each other
in general
because you plugged in these mu hats and
e hats in there
and this kind of induces dependence
across terms
but um the thing is that actually
under the assumptions we made that is un
um
under the assumption that you had mu had
w converged at four through
uh rights then these gamma hats are
close enough to be independent that you
can ignore this
dependence and you can build confidence
intervals
for tau as though tao had iip
aipw were just on average of gamma hats
and the gamma heads were independent
so you can just do the usual thing
um i'm spelling it out here but this is
really kind of if you stared at
this is just the usual estimate of
variance
uh for for a sample mean and this is
just kind of
the usual uh construct asymptotically
normal construction for
confidence intervals for a sample mean
um so you can kind of just really
do kind of very standard things for
building confidence intervals for tau
um once you once you're working with
this aipw estimator
so that's really nice um that's
essentially it's hard to kind of ask for
much more than that
in terms of guarantees uh
i just wanted to kind of close out this
discussion by highlighting a few details
that i neglected to mention in the
statement of theorem
but are still important the first
is i should put an asterisk
on the claim that you can just kind of
plug mu hats and e hats into the aipw
estimator
and everything is fine as long as these
are accurate this is almost true
but to make this actually true you need
to use
this algorithmic trick called cross
fitting
if you're familiar with cross validation
it's a very similar idea
the simplest i type of cross fitting
is you divide your data set into your
fit kind of
models on both half the data and then
when making a prediction for the ite
observation
if the ith observation is in data half a
use the model trained on data half b and
vice versa if the eighth observation is
in data half b
use the model trained on data hack a
so essentially you never want to be
making predictions
like mu had one of xi at the ice
um training example uh using a model
that actually got to see
the ice example while being trained
so that's something that matters
you you really should use this
most standard packages that kind of
do aibw based on machine learning will
do it for you
if you want to implement it by hand you
need to remember to use cross fitting
but kind of it's a little bit of effort
but it's really
kind of algorithmically it's no more
work than cross validation
and this kind of the guarantee you get
out of um cross fitting is that kind of
idiosyncrasies
of how machine learning methods use
individual data points
don't affect your guarantees
so this is the first detail
the second is i did have one more
assumption
on the slide so kind of
for aipw to give good estimates of the
average treatment effect you need
uncompoundedness you need the machine
learning methods to be reasonably
accurate
and the third thing you need is you need
overlap
and overlap here
means essentially that the propensity
scores can't be
get too close to zero or one and
specifically i'm going to assume that
there's kind of positive constant eta
such that kind of everyone has at least
a probability
eta of being treated and at most the
probability one minus eight
have been treated there are no people in
the data set who conditionally on x
are essentially deterministically sent
to control
for treatment there are many reasons
you'd want to have overlap conceptually
it might feel kind of funny you try to
estimate treatment effects um
in a data set where some people are
deterministically a sign of treatment
and
or control and there's kind of no kind
of genuine treatment variation
uh if you kind of feel worried about
that
you're right you feel worried about that
another kind of just
more algorithmic argument for why you
don't want propensity score close to
zero or one
is that in this kind of variance of aipw
you're dividing by e of x and one minus
c of x
and if you're dividing by e of x
and e of x is close to zero that's going
to blow up so
essentially even if you even kind of
given all the guarantees we have here
if you let propensity scores get close
to zero or one
your variance is going to be very bad um
and
your treatment effects won't be accurate
so
which we do about this uh in
applications i'd recommend you kind of
think about overlap
uh it's generally not something that
you'll need to worry about too much
uh for the kind of simple reason that
kind of in any given application you can
check
if you have overlapped or not it's not
like unconfoundedness which is kind of
one of these identifying assumptions
that you just need to kind of sit down
for a long time and think about whether
you believe in it or not
but you can't validate from data um
overlap
right if you're running aipw you have
estimates of the density score
so just every time you have propensity
scores
make histogram if the histogram is kind
of nicely
between zero and one far from the
extremes you're in good shape
uh if spiking is their own one uh you
may have a problem
and so just um you show this in the case
of an example
um from a paper from susan and and
co-authors
um they were studying um
a setting where you have um you want to
study different
auction mechanisms and the question was
what's the effect of using
on a sealed auction versus an open
ascending auction
and they have data from idaho california
here
here we say that an auction is treated
if it's sealed and the propensity score
would be the probability conditionally
uncovered that the auction would be
sealed so then kind of here
in this data set you can kind of do what
i was suggesting that is
make histograms of the propensity scores
in both idaho and california
and see how it looks um
in idaho everything looks good so this
plot actually shows density plots not
histograms
and it also stratifies by treatment type
so i believe this one
is a density plot for the treated units
versus for the controls
but overall you see you're in pretty
good shape
most of the kind of propensity scores
are
far away from zero and one uh you're in
pretty good shape
um you might
bubble that you have kind of quite a bit
of propensity scores that are kind of
stacked
on your zero here maybe you should be
estimating an average treatment effect
on the treated
anyways there are solutions uh to get
around these problems
but anyways this is looking very good um
on the other hand same dataset but in
california
all the controls essentially have a
propensity score of zero
and all the treated units essentially
just have a propensity score of one
which suggests that kind of most of the
data set
what was happened is kind of based on
covariates if you were control
it was that you were going to
deterministically be a control if you're
treated then you were going to
deterministically be a
treated unit and if your propensity
score plot looks like this
then you have something to be concerned
about and
you should do something about it um
what can you do about it there's a
number of things
um and this is this is kind of
um a fairly fairly wide literature
um i'm not going to go on it today but
you could kind of filter your data set
into regions where kind of
a better overlap your propensity scores
are less extreme
you could try changing the question uh
you could kind of
if you have a lot of propensity scores
that are close to zero but you don't
have a problem near one you could
estimate an average treatment effect on
the treated
uh this is kind of another alternative
to the average treatment effect for
which you can kind of do
everything we've done uh in this lecture
but kind of in separate
notation uh or kind of a slightly
different functional form
uh so i'm not gonna do that here
um but essentially you have a problem
but once you have know you have a
problem you can often
solve it and this is something i'm i'm
happy to talk with if you encounter this
kind of issue
um uh ask you on in your project
i just wanted to kind of really flag
this is the thing to be
paying attention to because every couple
months
someone kind of sends me a bug report
being like i tried to run aipw
and nothing was working and everything
blew up and then i asked them can you
give me
a histogram of your propensity score and
all their propensity scores are
deterministically zero and one
and then i can help tell them that they
were dividing by zero uh
and that's why they were having problems
anyways that's overlap
so in in recap um
what have we done in this lecture we
wanted to estimate
the average treatment effect um the
average treatment effect
uh is one of the kind of most standard
targets in causal inference
we wanted to estimate an average
treatment in an observational study
um and this meant that kind of we had to
control
in some sense for variables
x our pre-written covariates and
we wanted to use machine learning to
control these axes
to avoid making parametric assumptions
and at first glance right there are many
popular
ideas for estimating average treatment
effects you could do a regression
adjustment you could do
inverse propensity weighting and you
might think
i know what to do i'll take the
regression adjustment formula but just
plug in
machine learning everything's good right
no unfortunately not machine learning
methods are
pretty accurate but not as accurate as
parametric models
and not as accurate as parametric models
in
well-specified parametric designs so
then kind of that didn't quite work you
don't get confidence intervals out of it
and then you could look at ipw you could
again say hey i know what to do
i see an inverse propensity score i'm
going to estimate my propensity scores
using a machine learning method plug
that in and that's going to work right
and it's like not white it's going to be
consistent but we're not getting
guarantees
that are comparable to kind of good root
and rate parametric type guarantees
um that we need for confidence so
okay uh is the situation hopeless
uh no the the simplest most naive things
you might want to do
don't work but you can put machine
learning to good use for causal imprints
uh you just need to do so using the
right strategy
and here one good strategy is aipw
it's a kind of carefully designed
estimator the start with the regression
adjustment then uses ipw to correct the
regression adjustment
and in doing so cancels out the errors
of
the regression adjustment and ipw to
first order
you might think that i kind of just pull
this estimator out of a hat and then
it's kind of
strange but maybe that's true but i'll
just reassure you that
it's a big hat and there are many other
things you can pull out of that hat and
there's a
theory for how to do so um and kind of
really aipw is just kind of one first
example
of an estimator with this property if
you've heard terms like
orthogonal moments or double robustness
these are kind of very general terms
that apply to aipw but also apply to
many
other estimators so
that's that's the big picture uh
what's kind of the difference between uh
linear regression and machine learning
kind of one thing you could say is that
linear regression when given a
well-specified linear model
it has very good behavior parametric
behavior
it's errors to case one over square root
n and everything is wonderful
but in a general setting if the linear
model isn't right
then linear regression is inconsistent
you get the wrong answer
and that's bad machine learning on the
other hand
it's more flexible in a linear
specification
it's going to be okay in a general
setting it's going to be okay
the reason you want to use machine
learning is to kind of get
decent estimates of the thing you want
to predict under considerable generality
and that's good
using machine learning opens the door to
a bunch of flexibility
but the cost of doing so is that now you
need to remember that actually machine
learning methods whenever you deploy
them they're gonna have errors that are
generally a little bit
bigger than what you're used to when
using kind of parametric methods and
parametric models
and you need to use kind of
post-processing strategies that are
robust to moderate final
sample errors in the context of average
treatment effect estimation
we saw that aipw is one
solution with this property and kind of
throughout this class
we're going to be seeing more of them
all right that's all i had
for now i'm going to leave you with some
references
just here kind of the first three are
closer to what i was talking about today
they kind of outlined this agenda
in much more breadth um this kind of
first and third
you can think of more as kind of giving
you the agenda and kind of
generalizations of where you kind of
what are problems where you can plug
machine learning
in and get good um
get good kind of parametric type
guarantees and confidence intervals
or the causal parameter you're
interested in
and then kind of this paper flushes out
uh what i presented today but kind of
in the context that deep nets and
actually proves uh
the guarantees for deep nets that you
need to use to apply these results for
um i'm also putting these two results
here
today i talked more about this kind of
non-parametric setting there's a
parallel very similar kind of discussion
of what happens when you want to
use you're in a high dimensional setting
and you want to use methods like the
lasso
to estimate average treatment effects
there instead of things like
trees or forest or boosting like you
would in a non-parametric setting
i'm not going to say more about that
here but if you're interested
in the high dimensional setting then
these two papers are in place to get
started